john tu vas y arriver avance et ne te
retourne pas toute ma vie j'ai préparé
mon fils a dirigé l'humanité dans le
combat contre les machines
nous allons reprendre notre monde
mais il ya une chose à laquelle je ne
pouvais pas le préparer sinon vous les
fausser la donne
ils ont envoyé un terminator à l'époque
d'avant la guerre pour tuer ma mère je
vais y aller laisse-moi la sauver
viens avec moi si tu veux libre
vous savez qui je suis ça fait plus de
dix ans qu'on prépare ton arrivée qui
compte un terminator x 8 debout
rencontrer tu apprends à s'intégrer je
sais y'a du boulot salue maman comment
tu peux être là
qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait de mon fils
c'est toi qui m'as appris à survivre
descendez
je suis pas une machine
je ne suis pas une taupe
c'est plus que ça
j'peux pas l'abandonner je sais pas ce
qu'elles ont fait à john et il faut
qu'il redevienne ce qu'il était
tout a changé
on est le dernier espoir de l'humanité
recharge
que je t'attendais
débarrasse mois
je reviendrai quoi
et